bonsoir 1 et chiche merci d'être avec
nous que vous évoque cette peur et
surtout ses menaces que subit votre
collègue
tout d'abord je voudrais commencer par
signaler que je ne connais pas trappe
et c'est donc je ne vais pas parler de
ce que je ne connais pas mais en
revanche il se trouve que je connais
bien le didier d'une mère on a été
professeur débutant ensemble et je peux
témoigner que c'est quelqu'un qui se
fait une très haute idée de son métier
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on ne
peut qu'être scandalisé que il se doit
se rendre à se glisser sous escorte
policière
maintenant je suis aussi un peu gêné par
l'emballement médiatique que c'est
occasionne
parce que bon les faits à part le fait
que la police ait jugé qu'il devait être
surveillé protégé et les faits pour
l'instant il n'y en a pas j'ai été assez
sensible aux témoignages des élèves que
vous avez passé juste avant je pense
effectivement que il ne faut pas que
l'arbre de l'islamisme radical cache la
forêt l'état dans lequel se trouve
actuellement l'école sur tout le
territoire et pas seulement à trappes
s'il ya bien un territoires perdus de la
république c'est celui de l'éducation et
notamment parce que tout ce qui relève
de l'autorité avait été tellement
caricaturer et stigmatisé rejeter que
désormais quand l'autorité est affirmée
elle et elle est d'emblée perçue comme
de l' autoritarisme et n'ont pas de
l'autorité de l'autorité c'est
simplement la capacité à dire ramener
chacun à sa place est à dire mon
tranquillement quand il faut dire non
c'est à venir orner juste parce qu'on a
on est jaloux j'ai du mal à vous suivre
je voudrais être sûr de bien comprendre
vos propos aujourd'hui qui fait de
l'autoritarisme selon vous dans cette
affaire donc cette affaire non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que dans au sein
même de l'éducation nationale
l'institution en tant que tel renonce à
affirmer l'autorité a commencé par
l'autorité du professeur lui-même dans
sa classe vous savez là on parle d'un
collègue qui est sous-estimé colistière
mais il ya quelques mois avant la
décapitation samuel ati on a vu sur les
réseaux c'était le déclenchement du
phénomène pas de vagues
on a vu sur les réseaux sociaux une
image prise en classe par des élèves
d'un professeur qui était mise en joue
par un autre élève qui tenait une arme
qui s'est révélé être une arme factice
mais qui aurait pu être une arme réelle
et cette image elle est dramatique parce
que elle montre à quel point il y a
effectivement un problème de l'autorité
dans l'institution scolaire à partir de
ce moment là effectivement le moindre le
la moindre parole peut être mal
interprété et donné lieu à ensuite une
extrême comment dire une récupération
sur les réseaux sociaux ou des
interprétations sur les réseaux sociaux
et de fil en aiguille cela revient dans
les oreilles des uns des autres sur la
forme de menace c'est à peu près ce qui
s'est passé dans le cas de samuel cathy
se trouve que ces menaces ont été prises
au sérieux par par un illuminé de
l'ariège monde et j'espère que bien
entendu il n'y aura pas de même de mon
collègue didier lemaire mais je voudrais
quand même rappeler que sur l'ensemble
du territoire en france il se passe des
choses comme ça tous les jours et que la
plupart du temps les professeurs ne
bénéficient pas d'une telle audience
médiatique il ne
ils n'en font pas état ils rasent les
murs où ils sont parfois même persécuté
par leur propre hiérarchie parce que
elle même ne veut pas faire de vagues
justement ce n'est chiche justement
parce que c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites parce que vous vous disiez voilà
je suis un petit peu gêné devant
l'emballement médiatique de cette
affaire mais enfin c'est quand même une
mère des deux des lèvres d'ailleurs qui
lui ai dit si vous continuez vous vous
allez peu 2e samuel pâtit une enquête a
été ouverte et pourtant les menaces
continuent ce n'est pas précisément et
malheureusement cet emballement
médiatique qui va peut-être protéger
votre collègue parce que samuel pâtit
n'a pas été protégé on a lu ici ou là
alors je ne connais pas les détails de
l'enquète mais qui n'a été d'une
certaine manière un petit peu lâché par
sa hiérarchie par certains de ses
collègues aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
pas ce projecteur médiatique qui peut
protéger ce genre de professeurs menacé
certainement mais vous savez des
affaires comme ça il y en a depuis très
très longtemps moi je me souviens d'une
époque encore lointaine il ya une
quinzaine d'années ou un autre de mes
collègues professeurs de philosophie
également robert & decker avait été
avait été menacée pour un article qu'il
avait publiée dans le figaro et il vit
depuis sous protection sous protection
donc c'est pas nouveau ça que la
médiatisation de cette affaire protège
didier lemaire certainement mais tous
les autres ne bénéficient pas d'une
telle protection d'une part et d'autre
part ce que je voudrais surtout dire
c'est que ce qui s'est passé avec la
décapitation d'un professeur est
tellement grave qu'on se demande comment
quatre points après on en est toujours
là ça montre bien que on n'a pas du tout
la capacité à se mettre en face de ce
que nous n'avons pas bien fait et
effectivement un moment donné il faut
tout remettre à plat
est ce que vous vous pointez du doigt
ministre de l'éducation successifs le
laxisme de l'état ou autre chose
vous avez bien une explication justement
vous avez raison de souligner que ces
salles seul dans cette situation et que
c'est absolument inacceptable
oui oui tout cela effectivement les
ministres de l'éducation qui ne sont là
que deux passagers qui ne rendent
absolument pas compte de leur bilan une
fois qu'ils sont ailleurs et qu'il coule
des jours heureux ailleurs tandis que
les professeurs sont veut toujours au
charbon est toujours en train de subir
les conséquences de leurs de leurs
décisions les plus hautes autorités de
l'état qui obéissent aux mêmes logiques
qui sont dans la communication plus que
dans puisque dans l'action et peut-être
chacun d'entre nous aussi peut-être la
société tout entière parce que il ya une
responsabilité collective dans le
devenir de l'école si on fait de l'école
effectivement désormais le service
public qui garantit la réussite à tout
le monde on n'est pas bon d'être en
partie responsables du délitement de
l'autorité de la discipline
vous savez les menaces dont on parle en
ce moment elles ne doivent pas faire
oublier que la violence est une réalité
qui est présente dans l'école
quotidiennement et devant laquelle les
sanctions ne sont pas à la hauteur ou et
il faudrait faire quoi elle est dans la
répression selon vous dans plus de
prévention
moi je moi je n'ai même plus loin je
pense qu'il faut véritablement
réinstituer l'école c'est à dire mettre
chacun sa place à commencer par les
parents d'élèves à à la leur qui n'est
pas naturellement nul mais qui n'est pas
non plus celle qu'ils ont prises au fil
du temps les problèmes qui veut qu'on
les professeurs avec les élèves
ne serait pas ne prendrai pas les mêmes
proportions ce qui on ne donnait pas
aussi aux parents d'élèves d'une classe
qui n'est pas la leur je vous rappelle
que dans la sphère samuel pâtit c'est
quand même ça qui est commencement et je
pense que dans la sphère de didier
lemaire c'est c'est la même chose je je
suis professeur moi aussi et je même si
j'avais des élèves qui posait des
difficultés je pourrais traiter cette
difficulté s'il n'y avait que que les
élèves et si l'institution était
derrière en soutien en soutien des
professeurs un soutien implicite au
temps qui explicite jeudi un cli site
parce que effectivement une institution
qui met sur le même plan la parole des
professeurs ou des adultes et à parole
des élèves
elle a déjà commencé à renoncer à sa
mission fondamentale
les jeunes ont besoin d'autorité
contrairement à ce qu'on croit ils ont
besoin de repères 1
et quand l'école renonce à les leur
fournir ensuite effectivement on prépare
le terreau à à tous que l'on déplore que
ce soit la violence sociale en général
ou la mainmise de certains qui l'emprise
de certains qui profitent de notre
faiblesse pour ce pour se renforcer moi
je ne crois pas du tout que ce qu'on
appelle l'islamisme radical soit aussi
puissant qu'on le dit est aussi
dangereux qu'on le dit pour la
république
ce qui est dangereux pour la république
c'est qu'elle renonce à elle même on
laisse ensuite effectivement s'efforce
l'emporter merci beaucoup rené chiche
d'avoir été avec nos professeurs de
philosophie vice-président action et
démocratie
auteur de la d instruction nationales
merci à vous